here we come to the heart of the matter
I have never left a stumble never left
the houses streets and neighborhoods of
my childhood although I've lived in
other districts from time to time 50
years on I find myself back in the park
apartments where my first photographs
were taken and where my mother first
held me in her arms to show me the world
I know this persistence of something to
my imaginary friend and to the solace I
took from the bond between us but we
live in an age defined by mass migration
and creative immigrants and so I'm
sometimes hard pressed to explain why I
have stayed not only in the same place
but the same building
my mother's sorrowful voice comes back
to me why don't you go outside for a
while why don't you try a change of
scene do some traveling Conrad
Nabokov mindful these are writers known
for having managed to migrate between
languages cultures countries continents
even civilizations their imaginations
were fed by exile and nourishment Raunak
through groups but through ruthlessness
mine however requires that I stay in the
same city on the same Street in the same
house gazing at the same view Istanbul
faith is my faith I am attached to this
city because it had made me who I am
flubber who had who visited Istanbul a
hundred and two years before my birth
was struck by the variety of life in his
teeming streets in one of his letters he
predicted that in a centuries time it
would be Istanbul would be the capital
of the world
the reverse came true after the Ottoman
Empire collapse the world almost forgot
that Istanbul existed the city into
which I was born
for spoarer shabbier and more isolated
than it had ever been
it's two thousand year history for me it
has always been a city of ruins
and at end of end of Empire melancholy
I've spent my life either battling with
this melancholy or like all the stumbles
in making it my own at least once in a
lifetime
self-reflection leads us to examine the
circumstances of our birth why were we
born in this particular corner of the
world on this particular date these
families into which we were born these
countries and cities to which the
lottery of life has assigned us they
expect love from us and in the end we do
love them from the bottom of our hearts
but did we perhaps deserve better I
sometimes think myself unlucky to have
been born in an age in an aging and
improvised City buried under the ashes
of a rune Empire but a voice inside me
always insisted this was really a piece
of luck if it were a matter of belt then
I could certainly count myself fortunate
to have been born into an affluent
family at a time when the city was at
its lowest ebb though some have Abele
argued the contrary mostly I'm
disinclined to complain I've accepted
the city into which I was born in the
same way I accepted my body much as I
would have preferred to be more handsome
and better built and my gender even
though I still ask myself naively
whether I may have I might have been
better off had I been born a woman this
is my fate and there is no sense arguing
with it this book is about this fate
you